ready yeah growing up I was always just
doing like as many different things as
possible I always loved learning
something new and trying new things
so yo-yoing was just kind of one of
those things and it's an easy hobby to
pick up it's something you can do all
the time whether you're waiting in line
at the movie theater or like waiting for
a table at going out to dinner and you
can carry it around in your pocket it's
just something I just stuck with did he
ever my name is Gendry Stein and I'm a
world yo-yo champion check it out so
yo-yos are my job so I basically compete
in yo-yo contests travel all around the
world to teach people how to yoyo and
basically just share my passion for yoyo
sign is more passion than most you for
this toy it's love at first sight when
school kids get a glimpse of the latest
in yo-yos and yoyo techniques yo-yo is
hardly a new amusement the ancient Troy
was once made of clay and dates back
centuries and that's kind of the stigma
that yo-yos have because it kind of
started as just a simple toy and really
it is a simple toy but as the design of
yo-yos has changed it's become a lot
easier to learn how to do tricks with
them and you can do a lot crazier tricks
but gone are the days just shooting the
moon and walking the dog Maya is rollin
sealed ball bearing axis and slippery
synthetic strings which have opened up
entirely new tricks and routine really
since there's such little friction like
the yo-yo is gonna spin for anywhere
from two to ten minutes so if I'm doing
tricks I could do a whole trick that's
like a minute long and the yo-yo is just
on one throw sign is one of the best at
making the most of a throw he's captured
audiences with his mastery of
sophisticated tricks the flashy style an
elaborate routine set to music like this
one he created for us a lot of yo-yo
players are really into the technical
side there's a lot of aspects that you
can really dive into but something that
I try to do is have a really
well-balanced routine and some
is cool for an audience to watch it's
cool for people who maybe Joan yo-yo or
don't really know what modern yo-yoing
is and so if you have long enough spin
you can do tricks that are really big
and landing on the string really hard
and so let's say you're trying to
choreograph to music and land on like a
really hard eat you can you know do a
trip where the yo-yo shoots way up in
the air and lands really hard and they
are still gonna be spinning and you can
continue a trip that way res with some
of the older yo-yos you would be trying
the trick and maybe ten seconds a new
yo-yo is already almost out of spin so
they're really kind of limited what you
could do with a yo-yo but now that they
spend so much longer the shape is a lot
wider you can really just do so much
more with it oh I'm sorry
behind the seemingly effortless routines
are thousands of hours of practice this
year I practiced about six to eight
hours a day for like almost the entire
year for the world contest but a lot of
that practice involves like building the
whole performance so it takes time to
create the trick once you've created
your tricks you can start building your
routine once you've built the routine
and it just comes down to practicing the
routine as many times as possible and my
finger is starting to like really hurt
from the string all those hours can take
a toll so I build up a callus on my
finger where the yo-yo is here because
it's constantly pulling on it and then
as you're practicing a lot you kind of
get like a rope burn on your hands so
sometimes I'll wear like a glove to help
protect my finger his dedication and
showmanship one in a world yo-yo
championship when he was just 18 years
old creating something and then
performing that creation for an audience
and feeling the energy that the audience
gives to me after they see that creation
is like that feeling just never got old
and it's just something I fell in love
with since then he's continued to refine
his technique and compete at the highest
level the tricks that you see me do now
probably look crazy but that's because
it's been like 10 years of like building
up for more basic tricks and a lot of
the tricks I'm doing too are very like
basic simple things that are happening
but they're happening like a lot of them
are happening in a small amount of time
and like all yours he started with the
basics so there's a foundation of tricks
that you can learn when you're first
getting into
then once you reach that certain level
then really that sets you up to create
all kinds of different tricks that maybe
no one has ever seen before so it really
becomes like this performing art where
you're showcasing like these creative
maneuvers and movements Stein showed us
a few foundational moves and how he
builds on them to create intricate
original tricks the first set of moves
you broke down or mounts and all amount
really is is landing the yo-yo on a
string with the string around your
fingers in a different formation those
formations can be super basic like the
trapeze where the yo-yo swings around
the index finger or they can be a bit
jazzier like the double or nothing mount
where the yo-yo is wrapped around even
more fingers or the wrist now where you
guessed it the yo-yo hangs near the
wrist basically with all these mounts
they're just building blocks to a bunch
of different tricks that you can do just
like mounts hops can be building blocks
to more advanced tricks this is one of
my favorite tricks called Eli hops it's
a really flashy trick where the yo-yo
hops off the string and there's a bunch
of different ways that you can hop the
yo-yo out the string you can just do the
regular way you can do it over your arm
over your head and you can even do a
horizontally the last type of move at
stein broke down for us
slack's where the yo-yo creates a bit of
give in the string and to do that you
basically just pinch the string
somewhere and loosen your hands a little
bit so you create this slack here that
you can start some maneuver with in all
of your tricks slacks are useful in a
bunch of different tricks like this one
that's time created you can see
throughout this trick I keep pinching
the string to create a slack and then I
use that slack and a bunch of different
ways to make the trick super cool watch
that trick again there's a reason why
he's a world champion put slacks and
hops and mounts together
and you've created your very own
original trick like this one I might do
some hops to start put the yo-yo in a
position where I can do a slack find
myself in that double or nothing mount
again
and from here there's pretty much
limitless possibilities of the different
things you can do working horizontally
opens up a whole new set of
possibilities
these are super hard on a vertical trick
you're not actually going to be able to
utilize the horizontal plane very much
because the centrifugal force of the
yoyo is forcing it to stay on this same
plane so what you can do to actually
open up a lot of different possibilities
is make the yo-yo horizontal where it's
spinning sideways in front of you and
then you can completely utilize that
horizontal plane and it's going to allow
you to do a lot more crazy tricks but
with those crazy horizontal tricks come
new challenges as you're practicing
vertical tricks at any time you can stop
and kind of analyze what you're doing
and maybe figure out what kind of step
you want to take next if you're creating
a trick but the reason why horizontal
tricks are harder is because you can't
stop the yo-yo at any time because it's
just gonna fall off the string and ruin
the trick so with all horizontal tricks
you always have to keep the yo-yo moving
the whole time and if anytime you want
to stop the yo-yo you have to
immediately change direction as if that
weren't high enough Stein brings the
yo-yo down by his knees making these
horizontal tricks even more difficult
the thing is with these tricks though is
your hands are actually pointed down
instead of up so it kind of takes a
whole different level of skill to be
able to do a horizontal trick downward
like this and then of course there's the
performance side of things something I
really like to do to take the tricks to
the next level is start incorporating
body movement and this to me makes the
trick look a lot more interesting and if
you want to get extra flashy you can
even jump over the yo-yo
[Music]
I think what makes you a living so
appealing to anyone is the fact that
anyone can do it you know a lot of kids
might be really good at math in school
or might be really good at sports but
some kids don't really find that thing
that they're really good at and they can
really thrive in and so a lot of time
yo-yoing can be that thing for them and
it can bring a lot of really special
experiences and into someone's life even
though it's just just a toy yeah
[Music]